[Music]
broglie's guys laugh is hilarious man
you're a [ __ ] mob boss or what like
this guy
are you mad what's up what do you do
you're what
but what is it why are 9 people
answering I'm asking one guy
what are you fault Ron why are there so
many [ __ ] I form the head but yes
well I'm a mob boss [ __ ] I'm asking
the one guy oh I got it I got it
[ __ ] chill the [ __ ] out dude the [ __ ]
is wrong with you guys
how many of you are together by the way
this is like 20 wow that's crazy cool so
is somebody's birthday or what ok cool
go bad we went down that row
what you say you're a recruiter you are
[ __ ] happen here okay
sorry sir I have to talk to the
recruiter what's that mean you just find
[ __ ] headhunter like you find people
jobs okay cool yeah I like how you acted
like it was maybe like you were the
predator the way you're saying it I'm a
recruiter I have [ __ ] hunt heads
really sounds badass I just you know I'm
fine people jobs go there it's pretty
badass if I carry a spear I don't but I
find people jobs that's cool that's a
noble thing man your job is finding
people jobs dude it's like Inception you
know I mean hold on a second your job is
to find people jobs
what kind of jobs do marketing I be
hilarious he was like baseball yeah
[ __ ] place the right fielder the
other day he was awful but it was 65
years old he went out and he [ __ ] it
didn't catch any fly balls and then died
but anyway I'm a headhunter marketing
okay cool very cool very cool cool are
you with that crew no no wrong I mean
he's a cool guy relax you know
no I'm not with that [ __ ] guy don't
make the [ __ ] mistake alright you're
with those two all right cool two chicks
hey one of them your girls are buzzing
than your girls are they friends or
what's the honorary wives cool to [ __ ]
Honore but wives I have to place one of
them into the job of my wife and I'm not
sure yet what do you guys do know what
you'd rather hold you longer will you on
[ __ ] my only fans or whatever the
[ __ ] they call that [ __ ]
only fans do that such it's hilarious do
you know about that like people people
girls on the Internet are like they're
on Twitter and they'll like cover their
nipples and they'll be like I'll be like
if you want to see the rest of it you
gotta pay and [ __ ] do the thing what
are you talking about dude if you're
paying for porn bye bye bye
dude what are you doing a paying for
porn literally just go on the internet
and go tits and then oh I could see them
I could see them no you don't do that
you don't do that you do do that you're
on the only fans is that what's called
are you really hahaha no way now it
seems like I knew and I'm not only fans
no that's not you that's you that's you
okay did he get you that job
[Applause]
you are a headhunter different kind of
head though you don't mean anybody want
to suck dick you know I'm a headhunter
that's what I'm hunting for you what
those tits got you those job yeah okay
great cool very cool and what about you
you do my own what is it called only
fans right why am i saying my own what
am i adding my to it like a cream yeah
but it's mine though you got you guys
are mine that's cool man so what is it
it's like you you you it's like an app
or yeah and then you click on it and you
subscribe yeah yeah yeah yeah I do
and and and then that's cool and it's
like a monthly charge or some [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah cool man
so juice yeah no I mean I don't know I
mean him no you know but like not really
that'd be [ __ ] hilarious if I get
into it this oh yeah I got into it
because I was at a show and this chick
was with a headhunter anyway she got
into she told me she was on only fans
and I you subscribed and now I can't
stop watching only fans and and then so
it so you set your price right like it's
yeah so all right cool wow that's
amazing and you make a good living doing
it
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] awesome that it's
Bank Bank really Wow
yeah are you on only [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just blacking out the dick if you want
to see the dick swipe up in my Instagram
story
[Applause]